[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de
télé fils tout de suite à l les titres
en images de ce lundi 26 juin 2017
une fois le diplôme en poche il faut
pour beaucoup d'étudiants se mettre en
quête d'un logement pour la rentrée un
nouveau forum vient de se tenir à
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines quelques
conseils à suivre
le salon du bourget vient de se refermer
retour toute cette semaine dans le
journal sur les géants yvelinois de
l'aéronautique qui participait nous
débuterons la part le groupe zodiac et
puis musique avec l'édition 2010 est des
clés si belle samedi amateurs de variété
française de reggae ou encore de rock et
est aux clayes-sous-bois pour une série
de concerts en plein air le 24 septembre
prochain les grands électeurs devront
renouveler une partie du sénat six
postes sont à pourvoir dans les yvelines
la droite départementale compte
actuellement 1 4 élus et parmi eux
gérard larcher le président du palais du
luxembourg il sera bien candidat à sa
succession et en cas de succès il entend
retrouver son statut de deuxième
personnage de l'état qu'il occupe depuis
2014 et qu'il a occupée par le passé de
2008 à 2011 à droite toujours sophie
primas la responsable les républicains
dans le département ou encore alain
schmitz l'ancien président du conseil
départemental
elle devrait également être candidat
c'est maintenant que se déroule la
course au logement pour les étudiants à
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines entend les
aider comme chaque année la sixième
édition du forum logement vient de se
tenir à l'occasion donc pour trouver une
chambre ou un studio est de récupérer de
précieux conseils le reportage de
nicolas landry d'un côté la famille
bouillasse de l'autre grégory trèfle
étudiants en m2 leurs différences
charlotte va entrer en première année
d'études supérieures à 3 i/s grégory va
faire lui un nouveau master 2
spécialités finance tous les deux
recherchent un logement pour l'année
prochaine avec plus ou moins de
difficulté un logement neuf ayant été
réservées sur une nouvelle réside
son a profité de ce forum pour venir
visiter la structure
location notre fille on ne demande pas
de papiers il faut être présent il faut
remplir des critères
voilà faut visiter parfois il faut
regarder la logistique qui a plein de
choses à regarder donc
c'est je trouve que c'est plus compliqué
pour faciliter la recherche de logement
étudiant saint quentin en yvelines à
développer sa plateforme look avis
objectif mettre en relation les
propriétaires avec les étudiants en
recherche de logement
là par exemple nous avons une
proposition de logement une chambre chez
l'habitant donc là vous avez le
descriptif la surface la disponibilité
des dates de disponibilité ainsi que le
montant du loyer différents acteurs
publics et privés interviennent sur le
marché du logement étudiant sur le site
de l'ue vs q le crous propose près de
400 place l'arpège plus de 450
les réservations peuvent se faire durant
tout l'été jusqu'à la rentrée en
septembre
60% des clients effectuent leur parcours
d'achat sur le net c'est ce qui ressort
d'une étude menée par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie qui a donc
décidé de lancer le mois du numérique un
événement pour aider les entreprises et
les commerces à se tourner vers le monde
2.0 parce que le digital est un vrai
tremplin de la relation publique et du
développement commercial
la cci a décidé de proposer une séance
sur le numérique à une centaine
d'entrepreneurs le but les encourager à
prendre cette voie sont des sessions
d'information avait une forme de
conférences et de tables rondes autour
de la relation et de l'expérience client
à l'heure du digital
donc nous espérons pouvoir leur
communiquer un maximum d'informations
sur la nécessaire transformation de
l'entreprise via le digital afin de les
accompagner à développer leur activité
et
le réseau commercial en effet lorsque
l'on compare avec nos voisins européens
plus de 80% des entreprises par exemple
en angleterre et en allemagne sont
équipés d'internet voire plus de 90 %
pour les pme finlandaise
il ya un retard tout simplement parce
que les entreprises et les entrepreneurs
pas tous mais un certain nombre n'ont
pas encore saisi les opportunités que
peuvent apporter de numérique et quand
je parle des opportunités c'est les
opportunités business le numérique peut
accompagner la transformation économique
d'une entreprise est trop souvent les
entrepreneurs les artisans les
commerçants ne le savent pas ou n'ont
pas conscience de la vente âge du
numérique dans la transformation
économique
et quand je parle de transformation
économique c'est comment le numérique
peut le ramener du chiffre d'affaires
additionnel des contacts et du coup
remplir les carnets de commandes
selon des études lorsqu'une entreprise
prend la voie du numérique à l'augmenter
son chiffre d'affaires de 50 % la cci
organisera plusieurs événements tout au
long de l'année
économie toujours et l'on vient
d'apprendre les chiffres du chômage pour
le mois de mai +0 6% en catégorie a soit
22300 demandeur d'emploi supplémentaires
le salon du bourget vient de se refermer
cette semaine nous vous proposons de
revenir sur ce secteur de l'aéronautique
sur saint quentin en yvelines premier
volet de notre dossier aujourd'hui lundi
nous partons dans les coulisses du
rapprochement entre le groupe safran et
l'équipementier zodiac aerospace
explications à nicolas landry stéphane
servant ce n'est plus qu'une question de
mois un géant français de l'aéronautique
devrait naître d'ici la fin de l'année
un projet solidement implanté dans les
yvelines safran a décidé de racheter lee
blinois zodiac aerospace une opération
financière chiffrée à 8,7 milliards
d'euros
spécialisée dans la fabrication des
moteurs le groupe safran avait déjà fait
une op à associer à une fusion en
janvier dernier une offre rejetée à
l'époque avant qu'une nouvelle
proposition soit faite au mois de mai un
nouveau format de rapprochement entre
safran et zodiac aerospace
qui doit encore recevoir les
autorisations des autorités de la
concurrence qui doit aussi recevoir
l'accord des instances représentatives
du personnel
et si tout se passe bien l'offre de
safran sera lancée en fin d'année et
aboutira concrètement au début de
l'année 2018
mais il est vrai que safran et zodiac
sont tous deux implantés dans les
yvelines
il est très probable que l'implantation
dans les yvelines continuera à se
développer pour soutenir le
développement de l'industrie
aéronautique zodiac aerospace 120 ans
d'histoire depuis 2007 le groupe
focalise son activité uniquement dans
l'aéronautique
installé à plaisir c'est un poids lourd
du secteur dans les yvelines en 2016 il
réalise un chiffre d'affaires de 5,2
milliards d'euros un résultat adossé à
la production d'équipements en cabine
sièges masques à oxygène ou encore
système numérique
plusieurs outils fabriqués notamment à
plaisir un site employant mille trois
cents personnes montre aujourd'hui sur
ce salon du bourget une sonde de
jaugeage de carburant qui utilise la
fibre optique et qui rend les avions qui
utilisent de plus en plus de composites
plus sur cette sonde a été développé à
plaisir par nos ingénieurs en
coopération avec notre autre site de
roche la molière mais on est extrêmement
fier de présenter cette innovation qui a
été retenue par boeing pour son boeing
777 pics qui arrivera d'ici 2019 2020
dans les investissements du futur nous
investissons sur l'avion de demain à
l'avion plus sûr plus économes en
carburant grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
une utilisation des innovations
technologiques préconisée par le
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre chargé du numérique
c'est impressionnant de voir le rôle du
numérique dans toutes les entreprises
qu'on a vu cet après midi que ce soit
dans les start up ou dans les grands
gros on voit qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
technologies elle passe par la mise en
oeuvre de technologies numériques qui
vont réinventer à la fois le métier
réinventer l'utilité et réinventer la
façon de fabriquer la façon de faire est
donc ce qu'ils meurent avant sur
l'industrie ces nouvelles inventions de
ses usages
un développement qui pourrait
s'accentuer avec le rapprochement entre
zodiac aerospace et safran de nouvelles
innovations pourrait naître dans les
yvelines loisirs à présent à une
bataille sans merci entre les huit
quartiers de monte
ils bretonne vient d'avoir lieu ce aide
dimanche pour la fête de la ville les
habitants se sont défiés à travers
plusieurs challenge sportif au parc de
la coudre et c'était la deuxième édition
des olympiades les participants se sont
investis comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images avec deux pères de famille et
voisins qui ont mené un combat sans
relâche on l'a plus de force mais pour
les grands mais c'est super sympa c'est
ludique et est en tout cas pour les
enfants c'est super marrant super rigolo
va très bien mais faut bon faut laisser
une chance à son adversaire dont j'ai
rêvé gagner en bas c'est un événement
qui est sympa parce que ça permet de se
regrouper avec les enfants tous les
quartiers faire des jeux des animations
dans un cadre convivial et pour terminer
ce journal direction le parc de diane
il a vibré ce week end au rythme des
clés si belle de 15 heures à minuit de
nombreux groupes se sont succédé sur les
planches pour une programmation variée
rock reggae pop ou encore soul la 23e
édition toujours aussi éclectique
ambiance rock'n'roll aux
clayes-sous-bois dit les chanteurs et
compositeurs bretons semblent
parfaitement à l'aise avec le public
yvelinois et même les wall of death
n'ont presque rien à envier à ceux du
hellfest tout le monde
[Musique]
les créateurs sont aussi dits publics et
c'est un peu ça que je voulais a
pourtant fait avec nolife c'est ce côté
casser un peu la barrière et pouvoir
aller au milieu des gens pensent que
parce qu'en fait on est tous des gens on
est tous je suis juste une fille
publique avant d'être musicien c'est une
grande scène et a pour un public qui ne
connaît pas forcément intégralement
plein de gens qui ne connaissaient pas
et du coup c'est cool de pouvoir revenir
sur une scène qu'on connaît pas
conditions comme celle là en plus on
avait franchement les plus d'une scène
beaucoup de place gagnant du tremplin
d'exception doit ils ont été
sélectionnés pour participer au festival
des clés civelles un jeune groupe qui a
pu partager l'affiché avec de grands
noms de la musique comme la chanteuse
imany ou manolo et sa musique gitane et
que les sybelles c'est à la fois de
permettre aux collégiens et aux
alentours de rencontrer des artistes de
renommée mais aussi de découvrir des
nouveaux talents qu'ils soient amateurs
semi-professionnels ou même
professionnel tourné c'est de faire un
festival qui justement propose des
vraiment différents styles de musique
pour qu'il y en ait pour tous les goûts
pour toute la famille pour tous les âges
c'est aussi ça la clé du succès des clés
si belle un rendez-vous toujours attendu
chaque année entre 7000 et 15000
personnes viennent profiter de ce moment
festif
tu
[Musique]
direct
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal les
programmes se poursuivent sur tv fil 78
n'oubliez pas les replays pour voir
toutes nos précédentes éditions
[Musique]